[Music]
welcome back to the next live show I'm
Stephanie Wong joining us now is
Jennifer Lin product management director
thank you so much for joining us thanks
for having me so for those viewers who
are just learning about kubernetes and
Borg
can you explain what each of those is
and how we're making kubernetes easier
to consume and the significance of how
each has evolved at Google sure
kubernetes is the externalization and
the open source of our internal
controller development container
orchestration tool called Borg it's
something that we've evolved over the
last decade and we have said publicly
that we launched four billion containers
a week across the Google environment so
managing that at scale we've learned a
lot about just running large global
scale systems and doing container
orchestration at scale in a resilient
reliable way kubernetes was open sourced
a few years ago and we've had our own
managed version of kubernetes with
google kubernetes engine now over four
years so a lot has happened in a very
short period of time but there's lots of
lessons learned under the covers we
continue to talk about API services and
open source why is Google
differentiating in this space yeah I
think you know this industry is changing
so fast developers writing new software
so it's really important that we get the
interfaces and how do we enable the
lifecycle management of services right
as a you know system and I think that's
why kubernetes has also gained a lot of
traction very quickly it sort of makes
the notion of a service a first-class
citizen and we've been very clear about
how to api's interact and how do we
essentially define services and do the
lifecycle management of services and
that's all coming with the maturity of
things like kubernetes and SEO yeah and
this is all enabling our developers a
lot of developers want to approach the
way that Google does and dive in and get
experience the way that Google develops
software how does open-source enable the
community and empower the community yeah
I think open-source has been the reason
why a lot of this has moved so quickly I
mean it feels like overnight it has
become kubernetes has become sort of the
container orchestration system of choice
just a few years ago there were so many
there was a lot of fragmentation a lot
of folks understood the value
proposition of containerization with
docker but essentially managing that at
scale at the system level there were
various options through open source I
think we've allowed a lot of people to
just number one understand
going on number to contribute in a way
that's meaningful for them and get a lot
of the use cases out there in the open
so we can iterate on best practices etc
and you know yes a lot of this has been
very focused on developer agility but
now as we move into sort of the maturity
of it yes a lot of the practices for the
operational administrators and sres and
making this essentially a production
level system is a lot of what the
community is excited about as well
that's great yeah open-source is really
focused on our users and we also want to
build our user experience into our
products can you talk a little bit more
about that and given that our cloud
users are different and they have
different needs how do we build that
into our products as well yeah I mean on
the product side within Google we do a
lot with the user research team to just
make sure we understand who are the
personas whether it's developer or a
security administrator or a network
administrator or the IT professional or
the user so just making sure we taking
sort of a use case driven approach and
understanding sort of who is the user of
the product and essentially you know
what problem are they trying to solve
and how do we hide the complexity and
make it a lot easier and make sure that
they're essentially doing their job well
but there are a lot because this is a
software stack with a lot of you know
we've talked a lot about decoupling and
separation of concerns you can have a
unified stack but you have to recognize
that there's lots of folks that
essentially are consumers of that set so
what's your advice for those who want to
move to the cloud with acceleration and
not have to do a rip and replace and
manage their existing lifecycle how do
they bring in cloud native yeah I think
cloud native has really been about sort
of openness and you know the flexibility
that we talked about today with with
anthos is really there are an
architectural set of principles which I
think kubernetes and things like sto
have kind of put out there in the open
source community there's a framework and
then there's an implementation so number
one I think the industry is really
rallying around the fact that container
orchestration there's sort of a clear
you know de-facto standard there
obviously we have our managed version of
that because there's a lot beyond just
the software bits in terms of how do you
actually you know do lifecycle
management and keep essentially you know
automatic upgrades patching security
updates etc as part of this system and
so that developers can move quickly but
you can keep essentially the security
and stability of the system
and one big part of the acceleration is
GK on-prem which was announced last
August and this is the first time we've
actually brought our technology into the
data center at this scale so why now and
why not sooner yeah I mean what we found
is everybody understands the benefits of
cloud but in many cases there's
technical and non-technical reasons why
they can't move all their workloads into
cloud overnight so this was a lot about
bringing the best of the kubernetes you
know stack and what we're doing with
Google cloud to the on-prem environment
and helping people move at their own
pace while at the same time modernizing
in place so it's not just about renting
compute cycles it's actually about
application modernization and developing
new services and adding more business
value etc so we're pretty excited about
that now it's not just on our GCP
resources but we can essentially run
this on you know third-party servers in
a private data center for the enterprise
and as we talked about today other
environments as well
so speaking of modernization we loved
your demo during the day one keynote
thank you
we heard a lot about modernizing in
place this year can you talk about how
anthos enables you to modernize your
applications no matter where they are as
you mentioned on-premises or in the
cloud yeah I think that's the nice thing
about you know kubernetes is you know
with anthos we're really thinking about
sort of open api's so that the
interfaces between those environments
number one we can hide the complexity
but still keep a consistent management
environment for the developers
independent of where those workloads run
they can learn you know one set of tools
and essentially evolve as the industry
evolves without picking sort of exactly
where that's going to run or you know
what production environment it's going
to run in because many developers don't
know they want to write once run
anywhere their consumers may be running
in many many clouds and similarly for
the platform administrator they don't
have to learn a bunch of different
vendor tools this framework is here to
stay
we believe it's going to you know be the
standard for many years to come so even
if that's not running in Google's cloud
per se that skill set that many
enterprises are trying to hire people
who understand kubernetes that's very
portable so people are willing to invest
in it now because it's it's going to be
here to stay for for many years and on
that theme we're hearing that developers
and operating just want to be managing
at higher levels of the stack but they
still want visibility and controller for
policy management at a service level how
is anthos providing a unified
programming model and
monitoring and policy across on-premise
and multiple clouds yeah great question
I mean with kubernetes obviously we've
really thought about container
orchestration and cluster administration
at scale you know with this deal we're
thinking about assuming most of your
micro services are now containerized how
do you look out for the lifecycle and
health of those services and the
interactions between those services how
do you make sure that those services are
authenticated and and that you can put
essentially policies around those
services without having to manage the
underlying infrastructure complexity and
then we showed how we're doing config
management and automating essentially
configurations at scale in a way that
essentially is declarative so you can
define the policies once and push them
down to different environments and you
don't have to rewrite them with a lot of
toil for each cloud environment and
that's really important for customers
that are thinking about let's say you
know PCI compliance or governance those
rules around how to have those security
controls in place don't change cloud to
cloud but today they're spending a lot
of time just to make sure they can you
know ensure audit and compliance in each
different environment so we believe that
sort of extra overhead that doesn't need
to be there and that was a key push with
without those many of our enterprise
customers they want to embrace new
technologies but it's not easy to figure
out how do I ensure that I'm still
reducing my costs keeping the efficiency
and you know addressing what the
auditors and compliance regulatory
environments are looking for right and
we actually know that not everybody has
a luxury of moving to the cloud
immediately for whatever reason how can
we help them get there yeah I think a
lot of it is I mean this has been a
great week so far I think the partner
community is very engaged I think a lot
of the use cases and the best practices
that are being put out there are based
on you know folks trying things out you
know sharing best practices we're trying
to take more of a use case driven
approach with fos I think a lot of what
we're trying to share is the operational
domain knowledge and the best practices
of us you know having run these systems
at scale but also tapping into you know
our hundreds of ecosystem partners who
are getting excited about it and
contributing back you know as this
matures and I think this is happening
very quickly in the last couple of years
but it really is about solution delivery
and not just
nology delivery with anthos all these
customers moving into production at
scales very exciting and you know
obviously as you said there are security
concerns how are we making that easier
for our customers yeah I mean we've been
you know security is a major
differentiator for us for GCP more
broadly and I think because
containerization is relatively a new
space we've been doing a lot with both
our customers and partners to do number
one you know education and awareness
around container security and secure
software supply chains and things like
binary authorization and C ICD and how
to make sure that security is baked in
way upstream so that when a developer
checks in code essentially it starts the
the you know governance process of
security and it's not a bolt-on
afterthought after the fact I think that
is a lot of the way that the Google
Google developers are when they check in
code essentially they don't have to be
an expert in security but the platform
takes care of a lot of the complexity of
security and governance thank you so
much for your time Jennifer thanks for
having me
[Music]
you